hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll the
world you may have heard is in a bit of
a mess
and I know you're immediately thinking
well which way is in a mess is it
because democracy is dying or because
the climate is falling apart or because
there could be another Global pandemic
all of these AI extinctions solar flares
there's a worry that bad things are
happening to the world so today's guest
Hannah Ritchie is here to tell us that
not everything is necessarily completely
impossible to solve so today's guest
Hannah Richie is here to say that for
certain problems we might actually be
able to solve them in particular the
environmental problems now this is one
of those things where it's a subtle
careful very specific message that is
easy to caricature so let me try to get
it right Hannah is saying that when it
comes to the environment so climate
change food sustainability pollution
things like that the situation is bad no
doubt that the city situation is bad and
getting worse in some ways but not
necessarily going to continue to get
worse that there are reasonable
solutions that are within our grasp if
we make the effort to do it so her point
is that there's a kind of inaction that
comes from just ignoring the problems
but there's also a kind of an action
that comes from being too sad uh too
Bleak in one's Outlook if you don't
think the problems are addressable you
don't do anything either so hen has a
new book coming out called not the end
of the world where she makes the point
that if we do certain things we can
actually bring some of these things
under control the climate and so forth
in other words there's not a threshold
that we reach where things just become
so bad that everyone's going to die okay
rather every little bit make things
worse and therefore every little bit
that we do to make it better is worth
the effort Hannah started out actually
as she says briefly in the episode as
kind of depressed about the environment
that's what she studied for a living but
it was videos by Hans rostling I don't
know if you know uh Hans rosling's work
he shows these wonderful videos where he
passed away he's no longer with us but
he would do these videos showing data
that indicates that in many ways the
world is a much better place now than it
used to be when it comes to Poverty
infant mortality lifespan things like
that on The Human Side we actually are
doing better so this inspired Hannah to
look for the ways that we can actually
do better and in the environment uh
maybe there are some of them it's not
necessary right it's not inevitable it's
not just going to happen but we can
pursue solutions that will have a real
impact and uh that leaves us plenty of
other things to worry about whether it's
democracy or AI or whatever but you know
the feeling that you can do something
and make the world a better place is a
good one so Hannah is the head of
research at our world in data our world
and data is a wonderful organization
that helps people understand what's
going on not just from the vague
Impressions they get from newspaper
headlines but from actually looking at
the data that's always a good thing to
do in this case the message is mixed of
course there's bad things going on
there's good things that we can do let's
not let the bad stop us from pursuing
the good with that message in mind let's
go
[Music]
Anna Richie welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank
you so you're gonna tell us that we are
not all doomed that in fact the world is
not going to end anytime soon this is a
radical claim uh how confident do you
feel about this
I'd like to carry out by by saying here
I'm talking about environmental dim
um I'm sure you've had other guests
someone speaking about other ways that
the world could end
um but I'm pretty convinced that on the
environmental stuff we do definitely
have the chance to about crises good I I
was going to ask about that because of
course we hear about threats from AI
nuclear war pandemics and so forth so
you're explicitly leaving open the door
to the world ending that way you're just
specifically focusing on the
environmental worries
I'm gonna deal with environment
that's fair that's a big enough thing to
worry about and because I want to make
sure because you're trying to say
something subtle and I know that it's
very difficult to say subtle things in
the public sphere when people want to
simplify everything so you're not saying
everything is fine right it's a little
more nuanced than that
definitely yeah I mean I'm from a
environmental background like all of my
degrees are in environmental science
um and I definitely come from a place of
feeling like we were doomed and on the
trajectory
um that we we couldn't move away from
um so I'm definitely not coming at this
from the angle of everything's fine I
mean my I've dedicated my whole life to
this because I'm really concerned about
it and I think it's a big problem but I
think these are solvable problems and I
think there are same for optimism for
how we can tackle them
let's just get in onto the plate like
why this kind of stance is necessary to
be said so clearly like you point out in
your book which is called not the end of
the world which I like as a title
um many young people have the impression
that humanity is doomed that is the
message that is coming across
environmental degrees where I was
studying this stuff full time and I
actually felt but at the end of my
degrees I was kind of at the stage where
I felt like I'd put all of my heart and
passion into this but I actually
couldn't make a difference there was we
were pretty much dimmed and there was
nothing really that I could do about it
um so yeah and I think I mean I know
from the emails I get the interactions I
have that I know that a lot of
especially young people but I guess
people in general feel this way I get
emails from from young people from
parents from grandparents that just feel
kind of at a loss of what they can do
about this
and part of your claim which I'm not
sure quite how one backs this up but uh
it seems to make logical sense to me
there is a complacency that sets in like
if we think we're doomed we actually
don't work as hard as we can to make
things better
I think there's a sweet spot in the
mentality of how you actually drive
action I think I like to call it like
cautious optimism I think there's one
side of optimism which is a is a very
complacent one where it is just the
everything's fine then you just sit back
and assume that things will get better
and they won't get better unless we
actively do that but I think there's a
flip side to that where there's a
pessimism can set in where there's no
sense of agency there's this feeling of
well we're doomed we may as well just
give up I think that's what I'm really
trying to push back against as a sort of
political issue It's Tricky right
because there are people on different
sides there are people who think that
everything is fine and you definitely do
want to push up back against that and
there's people who think there's nothing
we can do you want to push back against
that too you're pushing in different
directions
exactly
I think there are definitely a political
device I think there are closing to some
extent I mean I think over the last
decade or so I've seen in various areas
them closing and what I think I like to
communicate is that
the solutions that we have to go for
here need to be palatable for people
across the Spectrum and often the
solutions actually whether people care
about climate change or air pollution or
any of the environmental problems or not
many of the solutions they will adopt
anyway because they will be cheaper they
will be better so I think there are ways
that you can actually cross that divide
without having people everyone on the
side of oh we really need to tackle
climate change
and what is it that did change your own
perspective from thinking they were more
or less doomed to thinking that we can
potentially solve some of these problems
so I think when I
had definitely been
in this kind of rabbit hole of only
looking at environmental metrics so
throughout my studies I was just like
very laser focused on the environmental
stuff that was going on and I think most
of those Trends were definitely moving
completely the wrong direction which
gave me that feeling but I think
combined with that many of the human
developments I was completely unaware of
I think I just extrapolated the
environments getting worse therefore all
of the human metrics like hunger deaths
from natural disasters poverty all of
those must be moving very much in the
wrong direction at the same time
so I was very very ignorant and to some
extent or naturally what was happening
in the world and what changed my mind
was a guy called Hans Roslyn
um he's done loads of TED talks and
speeches where he basically uses data to
show that on most of the human metrics
um that we talk about there the world is
getting much much better and I've had
that completely the wrong way around
I bring that opened my mind up to well
if I'm totally mistaken about that maybe
if I step back to look at a lot of the
environmental data I might see it in a
slightly different way
and it's not just you right I mean I
think in your book you bring up data
from surveys saying that people I don't
know how Global these surveys are but
people tend to think that the world is
getting worse even in ways that it's not
it is getting worse in some ways like
you say but they you know get a mood
catches on and you think everything must
be getting worse
right I mean that was kind of
how to check because that he would ask
which are linked on the surface seem
like very simple questions like is
global HDM poverty going up or down is
Trail mortality going up or down and
most most people would get that wrong
they would think it was the opposite
um and this is a just a very very
consistent Trend and so let's think
about the trend the human like you say
the human measures child mortality uh
mothers dying and childbirth life
expectancy these are generally getting
better if I'm if I'm correct right yeah
they're generally getting better there
are still
saying
again and
on many of these measures still
completely unacceptable but we have seen
progress on all of these measures and I
think what's important is it's not just
a the rich countries in the world have
got much better on these metrics and the
rest of the world has stagnated
many countries in the world have moved
much slower but if you look at child
mortality it's Fallen basically
everywhere in the world so these are
trends that are truly Global and truly
moving in a positive direction well good
because that was gonna be my next
question uh will we get into slightly
finer grained details here is
it's always going to be a slight
oversimplification but are things
getting better everywhere and is that a
sustainable kind of trajectory
if you look at change over the last
century for example and in low and
middle income countries in particular
the last say 50 years
um most of the basic metrics of human
well-being have got better
they've obviously got better at
different rates and there are certain
regions where on some metrics things
have stagnated but in general yes you'd
say that for most human metrics things
are things have got better everywhere
and meanwhile uh the CO2 concentration
of the atmosphere and the global
temperature and the amount of pollution
Etc is getting worse
right so I like to
think about history for this like
basically like scales and to find the
balance so
um for most of human history we were
doing
you would say remember doing reasonably
well reasonably well on the
environmental Matrix we had low levels
of pollution CO2 levels were not High
um but we often would have like very low
standards of living so for most of human
history like chill mortality was at 50
for example where nearly half of our
children would die before reaching
puberty and over the last century or so
we've seen those scale steps where all
of these human metrics have got better
but there's been this conflict with the
environmental metrics and I think what
I'm trying to put forward in the book is
that we could be the first generation
that actually achieves both of these
things at the same time you can improve
the lives of humans today whilst also
reducing environmental
um pollution and protecting future
Generations so that's good because I
guess the worry would be that the cost
of making the world richer and
decreasing poverty and things like that
is dumping a lot of pollution into the
environment and you're saying well
that's not necessarily true
no that was definitely the case in the
past so you think about the past if a
human population wanted to produce more
food for example for most of human
history crop or agricultural history
crop yields were incredibly low and
there was just no way to increase them
so if you wanted to produce more food
you had to basically expand the amount
of Farmland that you're using and there
you would have to cut them forests and
Destroy habitats
um so there there was just an obvious
conflict of if you wanted more food it
came at environmental destruction the
same is true for energy you would have
to cut down forests in burn wood or
eventually we then burned fossil fuels
and so that was true historically where
we are at now is with all of these
technological innovations we don't we no
longer have this conflict in this
trade-off we can increase crop yields so
we don't have to cut down forests we can
use alternatives to fossil fuels and
just to be super duper clear we can do
those things it is not at all obvious
that we will actually summon up the
willpower to do them no I mean we're
seeing positive signs already but we're
we're not moving anywhere close to the
rate that we should be moving but we can
do it so at the end of the day uh your
book is titled not the end of the world
but it's a call to action to make sure
it is not the end of the world yeah I
mean get it needs to yeah there's two
ways you can see it you can say hey it's
not the end of the world that's
definitely not what I'm saying it's no
it's not the end of the world like we
can tackle this okay well that's the so
that's the the basic big picture I mean
let me just say one more thing because
you said it very nicely in the book that
you have a little Venn diagram just to
emphasize all these points the world is
awful it is also much better than it
used to be and it can be much better
than it is even now I suppose
free statements or almost anything or
like true at the same time okay good um
and it can be hard to sometimes hold
those three thoughts together but I
think that's really important so then
let's get on to the details that we can
worry about the you know what are the
environmental Trends going on that
should cause us concern even if they are
potentially addressable
if you just give this like the general
list then we'll go into details one by
one sure so I think the
to climate change
free deforestation
for growing enough food for everyone
uh five biodiversity loss and the loss
of Wildlife
uh six Plastics and plastic pollution
and then finally overfishing and the
destruction of our oceans
okay we're not going to get to all of
them because I want people to buy your
book so uh we'll hit some highlights and
you know feel free to uh expand on them
but I mean that's a
kind of depressing list I gotta say like
these are all real we Face them every
day
um how would you rank them like what to
you is the one that is the most pressing
I think in terms of
absolute numbers of people that it's
currently affecting the top of the list
for me is air pollution
um we often I think people often are
automatically drawn to climate change
and it tends to get the most press
coverage but if you're looking at
a number of deaths today from
environmental problems the number one is
air pollution so the estimates vary in
the that they're in the millions and the
kind of median estimate is around seven
million premature deaths per year from
air pollution
sorry say that again how many
seven million seven million yeah I
thought you said that that's a big
number that's a lot uh per year okay
um is it that's clearly not uniformly
spread throughout the world are there
hot spots where it's just really really
bad
yeah there's a I mean there's two kind
of key contributors to that one is what
we'd call indoor air pollution
and indirect pollution is basically just
an issue of energy poverty it's people
without access to gasoline or
electricity using solid fuel so burning
wood or crop waste or dung in their
house
um for for energy and that creates
pollutants within the household and
actually there you're talking about
millions of people dying every year from
that
um then there's what we would
most of us would think of as air
pollution which is the air pollution
outdoors from cars and burning fossil
fuels Etc yeah and there there's
definitely a Divergence of Trends I
think one is that people are often
unaware of how much progress-rich
countries in particular have made on
reducing air pollution
um I mean air pollution levels are a
mere fraction of what they were in the
past
um in contrast you've got many middling
middle income countries um which have
industrialized very very quickly and
they are air pollution levels are still
very high well we were just mentioning
before we started recording here you're
sitting there in Edinburgh uh I used to
live in Los Angeles and now I live in
Baltimore where this morning I got an
air quality alert on my phone but in
both Edinburgh and Los Angeles famously
the conditions for the air were really
really bad but we did we have succeeded
in greatly improving them
yeah I mean most yeah many
um kind of industrial cities across the
U.S across Europe used to be incredibly
polluted I mean we can't even really
Envision it today and and and when you
look at the data often they are I think
we think of air pollution in Beijing or
New Delhi is kind of unprecedented but
actually you could argue that you're
pushing in London or Edinburgh in the
past was actually higher than it is in
those cities today so I think what I
want to communicate there is that these
because we solved these problems in some
cities which should give us hope that we
can solve it everywhere it's not that
we're tackling this new problem that
we've never handled before we've been
there and we've actually succeeded in
reducing pollution well one of the
effects of uh going through your book is
that it gave me a new
thought or Insight or feeling about you
know the Sherlock Holmes stories or
Charles Dickens stories when they when
they talk about the gloominess of London
I always thought it was more or less
metaphorical but you maybe realize no it
was really just gloomy just to walk
around because of all the air pollution
yeah and I mean I mean there's just so
many historical accounts of of air
pushing I mean you've confined
um kind of damage tissue in the lungs of
mummies there's like writings from
ancient Rome ancient Greece I think we
think of air pollution as a very new
problem and it's not a new problem it's
been with us for millennia
but we have success stories right the
ozone hole acid rain we've already done
some good things
yeah exactly and I think
what's key about those problems I mean
we've we've managed to tackle local Air
Pollution so the UK for example air
pollution levels are much lower than
they used to be I think they are people
might make the argument that okay they
did that as a kind of nationalistic
thing it was not selfish but it it was
about protecting the nation and those
Solutions just don't scale to
International problems like countries
can't work together they might do it
domestically but they can't work
together but the two examples you give
there of the ozone layer which was truly
Global I mean every country in the world
signed on to this pact to to reduce
emissions
and then even acid rain there it was uh
like Continental Europe teamed up to
tackle it because emissions from the UK
would blow over to Scandinavia and then
there was also like tensions in the US
and Canada about who was going to tackle
tackle that so it's not just that we can
only tackle domestic problems we
actually can work together as countries
to solve them
so if many of the individual deaths
though are from people burning coal or
wood in their house uh worldwide is that
something where we can hope that just
making the whole world richer is going
to be the right solution here
because the problem is that
if you look at the trajectory of rich
countries to get to where they are today
took
maybe over a century and
we don't want low and middle income
countries to follow that same trajectory
the number of deaths that you'd have
under that curve if they were to take
the same amount of time as rich
countries did would just be
would just be unbelievable so what we
need to do basically is give them like a
short shortcut where they can skip the
whole trajectory that the US and the UK
had to learn from and say we can
actually do this much faster so give
them give other countries ways to heat
their homes other than burning coal
basically
yeah basically don't I mean the key to
air pollution is you you produce
pollution when you burn stuff yeah so we
need to not burn stuff whether that's
wood whether that's coal whether that's
combustion and uh engine we basically we
need the Technologies we need to make
cheap enough that they can basically
just skip the whole fossil fuel
trajectory you know we're we're told by
certain circles that natural gas is a
clean fuel that burns much better that
always seemed to be a little bit of
marketing to me less than reality I
don't know what your thoughts are
I mean it's certainly
so I remember talking about air
pollution here but when it comes to
climate change the US has managed to
reduce its emissions in the last few
decades and actually natural gas has
played a key role there it's basically
switched out call a natural gas for coal
and the amount of CO2 you produce
um from burning gas is much less in Coal
so to some extent
um natural gas has reduced emissions I
think there's debate there it was often
like proposed as this a bridge fuel that
we only needed it for a little while and
then we would quickly skip to the
alternative Technologies I think it's
still to be seen how much of a bridge it
is and how much of a no or just a
bedrocket is over Energy Systems well
there's a therefore a geopolitical kind
of issue here right I mean the U.S and
Europe and Canada have cleaned up their
act somewhat uh we put pressure on other
countries right like India and China are
trying to industrialize and you know
they're throwing air pollution into the
air and maybe 50 years from now Africa
is really just pumping out uh various
pollutants because they're
industrializing and and how
can we claim to have the moral High
Ground when we've benefited from doing
this first
yeah and then that's been the political
tensions and these climate agreements
for
um decades now I think they're I think
the argument there is that
rich countries need to acknowledge that
they've got to where they are from
burning fossil fuels
um that's not necessarily uh they're
really evil because they've done that
it's just the reality that they've
they've built their economies on fossil
fuels and if we don't work the rest of
the world to do that because we're
concerned about climate change then
basically there needs to be cheaper
alternatives for them to follow the same
development pathway they should not have
to
choose between Olivia and poverty or no
in carbon that's just like not
acceptable
so I think they are when people ask me
well the UK only emits around one
percent of the world's CO2 emissions
like there's actually no point in us
even like trying just doesn't make a
difference
but there were only talking about
domestic emissions what we need to think
about is the more like Global indirect
impacts of what the UK does the role I
see Rich quantities playing is one
taking the lead and reducing emissions
because they need that even from a
political perspective China's not going
to reduce its submissions if everyone
else steps back and says no
but importantly what they need to do is
invest in these Technologies early so
solar wind electric cars
um the low carbon Technologies and when
we do that we make these dramatically
cheaper and the point is we want to get
to the place where these Technologies
are cheap enough for the rest of the
world that they're not even tempted to
burn fossil fuels because they're
actually more expensive anyway so that's
to me where I see rich countries playing
a key role and maybe let's dwell on
these technologies that you mentioned
here because these are all
things that we hear about in the context
of climate change and maybe we can just
mix up that discussion but you're saying
that there's a whole nother worry about
burning fossil fuels even if the
temperature of the globe stayed constant
we're still breathing in a lot of really
bad stuff
right exactly so the these Technologies
um
really the aim there is that they tackle
multiple problems at the same time I
think that's a key point to come back to
when I read out the list of all of these
scary problems it seems often
overwhelming for people and often they
can certainly have is well if I make one
decision to tackle this maybe climate
change for example if I'm making this
one decision what if I'm making all of
the other problems worse so they're
constantly grappling with these
trade-offs that they think exist but I
think the reality is for most of the big
solutions to these problems they
basically filter through all of the
problems and they link together so
there's maybe only like five to ten
really big Solutions but the point is
they tackle all of these environmental
problems at the same time good that does
make sense and and therefore let's just
throw climate change into the mix here I
mean you seem from my perspective to be
pretty realistic in the book saying you
know look there's it's bad and it's
getting worse but you try to make the
point that we can make it better why
don't you just talk about like the
thresholds and the targets 1.5 degrees
Celsius four degrees Celsius whatever uh
people talk about
right so there's there's various targets
that we've set
um I think the distinction that I like
to make is that these are not what we
Define as thresholds I think one of the
problems that people have is that they
do think of them as thresholds
and what that leads to so if you think
about so we've basically set in the
Paris agreement we've said we want to
limit Global Temp to rise to well below
two degrees and if possible 1.5 degrees
now what many people interpret that as
is
1.5 degrees as a threshold and if we go
past that point it's just a tipping
front point from there and we're just
headed for doom doom and my key point is
we're going to pass 1.5 degrees that's
inevitable so if you're in that frame of
mind that that's the end and there's a
threshold then that you can obviously
see how people get in the position where
they do come into this doomsday thinking
um
so the rally is we're going to pass 1.5
degrees
um where we're currently headed is that
if you look at our current
um like policies on the table from
across the world
we're probably heading for around two
and a half degrees
no that's unacceptable and we need to
bring that down
but if you look at for example the what
governments have pledged to do so
they've said we're going to do this and
we're going to implement these policies
you can actually bring that down
significantly where you're actually
around the two degree Mark so what we're
saying is that governments the the
commitments that governments have put on
the table would bring us to around two
degrees now you have that Gap there
between what they're doing and what
they're saying they're going to do but
that's where we have agency because if
they said they're going to do it then we
can actually start to hold them
accountable to it let's dig into exactly
what this means what 1.5
above what do we agree on some baseline
and and what is what is it that we're
measuring is it the air temperature
average globally water temperature
yeah so it's the
average temperature arise from
pre-industrial okay and it's a global
average land sea temperature
land to Sea temperature I don't even
know what that means that just it
includes over the land NC yeah exactly
okay good because I mean of course the
climate is a messy thing that different
parts of the world have different
temperatures and so forth but implicitly
in what you're saying the climatologists
and Atmospheric scientists know how to
take an average and we can measure this
quantity
yeah I mean the when we talk about 1.5
degrees when you talk when you look at
the variation and what that means across
the world it's huge so this is like a
global average and actually a lot of
that is if you think for example of
um the amount of heat in you get over
land there's actually much more than you
get over the ocean right so you think
about heating over land it will be more
than 1.5
good and where are we now do you know
we are around 1.2
so you get kind of ups and downs this
year has been a particularly warm year I
think it's we're going to probably be
around 1.4 this year
um but the the average is around 1.2 at
the moment
and okay so we're 1.2 you've you've told
us
don't expect to stay below 1.5 we're
going to bust through 1.5 no problem uh
you hope that if we do everything right
we can avoid 2.5 keep it to two but if
we did nothing
my impression is we'd be busting up
there at four or five or six degrees
warm
yeah four or five degrees would be
definitely plausible if we didn't take
any action now if you look at even if
you look at I think there's this feeling
that we have been trying on climate
change for decades and we've made no
progress if you look at the amount of
progress we've made over the last decade
for example so where we thought we were
heading a decade ago we've brought that
down by around one degree so we're like
heading for 2.5 but we were heading for
3.5 so it's not that we're making no
progress that's a very important thing
to say because like you say the
political situation as well as the
scientific situation can lead one to
just despair sometimes so we already
have some progress not compared to where
we used to be but compared to where we
worried we'd be by now yeah exactly and
it
you talk about the absence of thresholds
like 1.5 is a Target and we're not going
to make that Target but it's not once
you get 1.5 the whole world just boils
over and everyone dies right but there
are
positive feedback loops right there's
melting of permafrost and things where
when a little bit of warming can lead to
a lot of warming down the way
yeah exactly
um but I think they are they are that It
ultimately comes down to probabilities
and there it's not a 1.5 threshold or a
two degree threshold it's like every
point one degree
higher you go you increase the
probability that you
reinforce one of these positive feedback
loops which I think is an important
message to get across that once we pass
1.5 which we will We Fight for 1.6 and
we fight for 1.7 and you just continue
fighting for that one point that point
one degree because with every element of
uh temperature rise you just increase
the probability that you you get into
one of these positive feedback loops I
like that so I'm just going to say it
again uh every 0.1 degree really matters
no matter if whether at 1.5 or 2 or 2.5
we still should work really hard to
prevent the next 0.1 degree yeah exactly
and let me I know better than this but
let me pretend that I didn't 1.5 degrees
doesn't sound like that much you know I
could get through the day at 1.5 degrees
warmer like what's what's the big deal
about all that
I mean the key thing there is the as I
said that's that's a global average
temperature rise when you look at
distribution versus the world the the
changes there are are much larger than
that especially at the poles so you get
the most severe warming at the poles
[Music]
um
so yeah 1.5 amplifies quite a lot
there's a lot of bad things that happen
uh when the globe warms what are the
relative importance of the different
things that are happening you know sea
level rise uh you know crops being
destroyed people moving from their homes
what are the things that we should
actually worry about here
I think the key one for me because I see
it as being having potentially the
largest impact on human lives is is food
security and and crop yields I think
because they're
they're often the most severe events or
the ones that are see highly seasonal or
they come with a warning and you're kind
of suddenly Frost into
um a situation where you you lose all
your crop yield you can't adapt Etc I
think some of the problems such as sea
level rise are to some extent gradual
there is it's obviously still
devastating but there are ways to adapt
to that
because it's a slower it moves at a
slower Pace whereas some of the impacts
on crop use could be very sudden and
seasonal okay and we have this weird
situation where there is a global
average that we track but there's
small disasters right and uh as we're
having this conversation California just
suffered through a hurricane which is
just unheard of California does not have
hurricanes here in the Northeast U.S we
had terrible air quality because of
wildfires in Canada and you know and so
on how
much are these individual disastrous
events connected to Global Climate
Change is it up zero relationship is it
a probabilistic relationship
relationship is is actually very
difficult to attribute a specific event
to climate change
um because there's so many factors
involved there there is actually a
specific project called the world
weather attribution Network I think it's
called okay where they do these really
in-depth analysis where they try to see
after an event what was the probability
that this event would have happened in
the absence of climate change and there
you do get varied results where some
they're like pretty confident that yes
there's a very high likelihood this
would not have happened there's other
ones where they think the the impact of
climate change was actually very low
okay
um so what should we do about it what
are we doing about it we already touched
on some of the renewable energy sources
but maybe let's just make that very very
clear is is it both good and plausible
to imagine a wholesale shift from fossil
fuels to other energy sources and if so
which ones
um I mean when it comes to energy so the
way I like to think about it is I
basically break emissions up into it's
around 75 energy in industry and around
a quarter food okay
um so when it comes to energy in
Industry I mean just the predominant
thing is to rapidly shift away from
fossil fuels and there we've got various
um methods to do so one is Renewables
the other one which is less popular but
I think is important is nuclear energy
which is another low carbon source of
energy and actually
there is the argument the if more
countries had really invested in nuclear
energy
1970s 1980s nuclear boom
um we might actually be in a much much
better position than we are today but
there is this is this mix of nuclear
solar wind those I mean Hydro still
plays a significant role it's just less
scalable than solar and windar I think
the mix there is nuclear you get you can
you can basically get high output with a
very stable at very stable level
that's the advantage of nuclear solar
and wind is where you can just get very
very fast growth of these Technologies
very quickly so if you were put in
charge of either advising or maybe
helping developing countries what would
you tell them to do would you tell them
to start building some nuclear power
plants as well as solar and wind
specific
nuclear is one
the potential for long construction
times with poor planning and one is
overrun like costs there are some
countries that are doing this very well
and doing it very quickly mostly in Asia
so uh China South Korea for example
they're doing very well and building new
nuclear plants I think there are some
countries where
um
there just may not be the knowledge and
the infrastructure to to build these
quickly and economically so there's I
probably wouldn't advise nuclear for
every country in the world
um my first go-to for
um low-income countries would be solar
solar okay I mean nuclear has
an emotional resonance negative
emotional valence with a lot of people
right there have been disasters there's
been Chernobyl there's been Fukushima
there's nuclear waste sitting below the
ground for millions of years or whatever
it is uh what is your feelings about
this or have they been overblown
um I know that statistically the number
of deaths is much lower per ERG or
whatever with nuclear than with fossil
fuels
yeah I mean get some I think it depends
on what you're comparing it to when you
look at yeah so if you look at the
numbers on deaths per unit of energy
that we've generated
um nuclear is incredibly low
[Music]
um
very I mean no one died in the Fukushima
disaster possibly one person in the
aftermath and there's debatable whether
you would attribute
deaths and people evacuating to the
disaster itself but in terms of the
direct debt from the disaster no one
died
um Chernobyl
was obviously a devastating event and
like I think what captured the world's
attention on nuclear energy but even
there when you're comparing the deaths
to the number of people that die from
fossil fuel burning every year I mean
you just have orders of magnitude of
difference right so while there is
inevitably a risk with nuclear power as
there is with most Technologies
um the risk is is very very low compared
to fossil fuels where it's not even a
risk it's just a constant you just
constantly have millions of people dying
every year from fossil fuel burning yeah
how do they die from fossil fuel burning
what is the cause
um so
um when we burn fossil fuels we
basically emit
um various Cassies but also what we call
particulates so like basically small
pieces of matter now the ones that we're
really worried about are are the worst
are basically the smallest particles so
you've got these particles we call them
PM 2.5 so they're like less than 2.5
microns okay and the point about these
small particles is they can basically
get into your respiratory system because
they're so small and through that they
increase the risk of respiratory disease
stroke Etc so many of the
non-communicable diseases that many
people die from
um air pollution significantly increases
the risk okay so it goes back to the air
pollution aspects of the of the fossil
fuels okay so if we imagine replacing
fossil fuels with Renewables and nuclear
and so forth what those produce is
electricity
and so we have to Electrify the world
rather than burning our fuels directly
in our cars or maybe even in our
airplanes and our homes certainly
yeah so the
the I mean the way I like to think about
it is we need to basically Electrify
everything or as much as we possibly can
we can get we can generate low carbon
electricity at scale
we producing other forms of energy in a
low carbon way is trickier so we
basically want to shift as much of our
energy to electricity as we can so the
key thing there is well one are existing
electricity demand but also shifting as
much transport over as we can and there
that's predominantly Road Transport I
think Aviation is going to be much more
difficult
but also in terms of heating for example
so switching to electric heat pumps that
basically takes off a lot of our the gas
that we burn for heating basically move
that to electricity as well so we
basically have this challenge of we need
to rapidly scale the amount of
electricity that will produce low carbon
electricity we're producing because
we're not just trying to meet our
current electricity demand we're
probably going to need to at least
double the amount of electricity we're
producing and meet that all through low
carbon sources
since you're in the UK is it possible
that you avoided the weird culture War
discussion about natural gas stoves here
in the United States a few months ago
are you familiar with this
I got like small inklings of it but it
wasn't as big here no all it was was you
know a proposed idea that we should
think carefully about the status of
burning gas in our stoves and you know
make sure that we didn't have too many
people dying of this Etc but then this
was instantly seized by a certain
political party as evidence that the
government wanted to take away your gas
stoves and you know
it's an example of how the political
problem is going to be a difficult one
right it becomes an identity that you're
not going to let the government take
away your gas stove just like your gas
burning car I guess
right I mean we've I mean we didn't
really have the gas burning stool thing
here but certainly in the UK there's
lots of backlash against electric
vehicles
um and there I think it's similar I
think so the UK government has basically
committed to
they're not going to sell new petrol and
diesel cars anymore
um so there's a phase out of new petrol
and diesel cars now I think there's
debates about whether they stick with
that Target whether they push it back
but I think a lot of the the messaging
coming from that which is untrue is that
there's this feeling of the government's
going to take your petrol car away from
you
um which is just obviously not the case
you just cannot buy a new one on the
market after 2030 but there has been
this
um definite backlash
where are you
see there being some bridge between
these political debates again comes down
to the technology itself
I think when you just look at a
fundamental the fundamental level of the
Technologies electric vehicles are just
much much better than internal
combustion engine
the Driving Experience is better they
waste much less energy you need to make
them
cost effective compared to petrol cars
and people will just make the switch
anyway they just it won't even be about
your pollution or climate change they'll
just pick the electric car regardless
2030 is pretty remarkable that's not
that far away I know that certain
individual car manufacturers like jaguar
in your country are as soon as 2025
they're just not going to build internal
combustion engines anymore it's a
remarkable shift from where we were just
a little while ago
yeah the
I think this is one of the reasons I
feel so optimistic is that it seemed for
decades that we're making no progress
and basically within the space of a few
years many of these Trends are just
really taking off so electric cars for
example
um you've gone from basically nothing a
few years ago to nearly one in five
electric cars in the world
um being electric new car sales
in some countries I mean China for
example we often think about it's the US
and Europe that are paying for the
expensive electric cars China One in
three new cars sold in China now are
electric and they're really going for it
I expect that within the next few years
you'll be hitting almost half of new
cars in China being electric so this
this kind of shift in in feeling from
Petrol to electric cars has been
incredibly incredibly fast and there is
a certain contrary intake that even
though you're not burning gas in your
car electric cars are bad for the
environment in other ways because they
need all sorts of resources we have to
dig up in mines and in poor countries is
that is there some truth behind that or
is it a little bit exaggerated
I mean there's various claims that that
go around
um I think the
the ultimate point there is that none of
these Solutions are absolutely perfect
it's not that you you're just not going
to find a solution that has zero impact
and I think if we're gonna try and wait
for that we'll just be waiting forever I
think the key point is we need to move
so we need to move with the solutions
that are really really good but not
perfect
so it comes to example from the the CO2
missions from electric vehicles the
point that's often made or claimed is
that you need lots of energy to produce
the battery and therefore over the life
cycle of the car actually you emit just
as much as a petrol or diesel anyway
that's just completely not true you do
emit more in the production of the
battery compared to the to just
producing a a regular gasoline car but
for the average driver you're paying
that back within one to two years so
like after one to two years you're
saving carbon and over the life cycle of
the car it depends on
the electricity mix
um but by the way even if you're
producing that associate from coal it's
still better than a petrol car but for
kind of standard electricity it makes
you're talking about reduction of at
least half often two-forwards in terms
of CO2 reductions and that will just get
cleaner as we decarbonize the
electricity grid
um to the point where you have very very
very low emissions for electric cars do
you drive an electric car yourself or
are you just because you're lucky enough
to live in a country with good public
transportation do you not need to
often come across
across I think Advocate or fanatic
um because I I do a lot of writing on it
but I actually just don't own one
because cycling or walking is better
it's just the an electric car is better
than a petrol car even better yeah
cycling you're walking is even better
than the electric car we have two cars
and one we keep in the garage for road
trips which goes on gas and the other is
the little BMW I3 which is electric and
it's so much fun to drive I love it and
I think it's going to be an easy
transition myself one but of course the
countries need the infrastructure right
the charging stations and everything so
it will take a while
yeah I think that it will take a while
when it's a big it's a big
infrastructure challenge like both in
terms of what one skill in other two
vehicles but even
decarbonizing the electricity grids
there is just a massive infrastructural
challenge we're just completely
rebuilding our Energy Systems and we
shouldn't underplay like the size of
that challenge
um but I think when it comes to to
electric cars and infrastructure I think
for a long time there was this kind of
range anxiety where people were worried
that the range of electric cars were
were too low and I just I don't really
see the case for that anymore I think
what's more valid is what we'd think of
as like charger anxiety where there you
are actually relying on there being
reliable working Chargers a reasonable
Cadence
um across Networks
but it but it is coming in I guess one
of the lessons here since you're trying
to be overly not I should say overtly
not overly optimistic in the book is
that
we've already seen that there's no
direct coupling between CO2 emissions
and economic growth right that is
something that we've we've demonstrated
the economies can grow without polluting
the atmosphere
for rich countries in recent years I
mean for most uh like most of the last
century it was true that these were
tightly coupled and it still is tightly
coupled in low and middle income
countries as economies grow CO2 missions
do rise what we've seen over the last
few decades in rich countries is yes
this decoupling where
economies have grown well they've
reduced emissions at the same time
now the question that always comes up is
is that just because they're just
offshoring all of their emissions
elsewhere so like they just get rid of
all the industry in just the rest of the
world produce these stuff for them
we can adjust for that and when we
adjust for that emissions in the US so
the UK are higher so we are net
importers of of emissions but even when
you take account of that emissions have
fallen so emissions have fallen while
GDP has increased so that's certainly
true in rich countries we're still to
see this decoupling
further down the income Spectrum
and I guess one other thing on the
climate change issue how much interest
do you have in active Technologies to
change the atmosphere to remove CO2 or
to otherwise engineer a return to what
the temperature was a century ago
[Music]
um
definitely a lot less than just simply
reducing emissions okay I think I mean I
think the I don't know how much it's
overplayed it's often discussed as
doing one comes at the cost of reducing
emissions at the same time
[Music]
the what I want to be clear is that the
primary focus is to reduce emissions as
much and as quickly as we can
there are certain sectors where
we may struggle to basically get rid of
our missions and there you would we we
may need to rely on negative emissions
Technologies to get us over that final
hurdle to get to Net Zero
um but I
there's so the first and foremost
through GEOS emissions I think the
question is if we want these
Technologies to be ready in 2050 when we
might need them
do we need to be investing early and now
and the answers maybe probably yes so
you think about Technologies I mean the
point of these Technologies is there are
varying energy so if you take direct air
capture so it's basically directly
sucking CO2 out of the atmosphere
they're energy intensive and they're
very expensive so we could not deploy
them at any scale at the moment
but you would have made that argument
about solar or wind or batteries several
decades ago as well they were really
expensive and didn't look like they
could be scalable so the question is do
we need to be investing in them now to
have any sort of viability in 30 or 40
years from now and the answer is
probably yes so I think these should be
still some small amount of budget going
into these Technologies but the primary
focus should be reducing emissions way
back when years ago I had rames Nam on
the podcast and he made the point that
uh solar power costs have plummeted of
course but it's not because we had any
great scientific technological
breakthrough was just because we built a
lot of them and got better at it and so
you know the cost went down as we
learned how to do it and and I'm not
sure if that's an analogous situation
for what you just called negative
emission Technologies
I think it's exactly the same I mean
it's just what we'd call a learning
curve yeah and you've seen the same for
Batteries you've seen the same for wind
energy whereas you deploy more you
basically have this continual learning
for throughout and yeah we've seen like
talking about like 98 declines and costs
over a few decades
um so it's been this very very dramatic
change but it has been this gradual
reducing by I think the learning curve
for solar was something like reducing
costs fell by 90 every time you doubled
capacity
so it's just been this constant I think
this comes back to what I was talking
about earlier of the responsibility of
rich countries yeah this has only
happened because
someone was investing in Technologies
when they were very very expensive and
the point there is it was rich countries
quite rightly but what's happened there
is the costs have fallen and they've
Fallen because we've had this gradual
learning over time
and I feel okay just to switch gears
that I've been a little unfair because
talking about pollution and emissions
and climate change is just inevitable
and fascinating we had to do it but I
don't want the audience to get away
without realizing that a major theme of
your book is food how we produce it how
we eat it and that is something you hear
a lot less about I think in the popular
discourse so what's up with food why
don't you like hamburgers Hannah
at the heart of sustainability for me
because it basically touches on almost
all of our environmental problems so
we use half of the world's habitable
land for farming so we've basically
turned the one the world into a massive
Farm yeah
um it's around a quarter of greenhouse
gas emissions
around
78 of fresh water withdrawals are for
agriculture and farming is the leading
driver of deforestation it's leaving
driver of biodiversity loss so basically
we cut most of the issues that I'm
talking about we cannot tackle unless we
tackle food
um
and when it's obviously there's the
environmental lens to that there's often
there's obviously also the human lens
but we're trying to feed people eight
nine ten billion people on nutritious
diet at the same time so that's the the
challenge that we have like can we feed
10 billion people well also tackling
these problems at the same time
so it's inevitably coupled to the
population question so maybe we should
get that on the plate as well our
population is growing we already have a
lot of people in the world it's growing
more slowly than it used to to the
extent that some people are worried it's
going to start shrinking do you have a
way that we should be thinking about
that
I think it's common in environmentalism
to pin all of our problems on population
and if we just have less people then the
problems would go away
often when environmentals talk about
this they're not talking about
slightly slowing down the rate of
population growth or slightly reducing
the number of people they're saying
we can only have sustainability on the
planet with one million people and
obviously that's just not realistic and
it's not even it's not even what I would
claim we should be going for
I think
to me the question of population is
overhyped in this I think the key reason
is that people
overestimate how quickly
demographics can change like we're
talking about tackling these problems
within the next few decades
the world's population is not going to
shift enough for that to make a
discernible difference on what we need
to do if we can feed eight bullying
people and produce low carbon energy for
eight billion people we can do it for
nine billion people or ten billion
people versus here we're talking about
providing scalable Solutions and the
bullions and when we get to that point
these small changes in population that
you may get from from
um some of the solutions that people
would propose they just don't make a
difference and the expectation now is
that the well let me phrase there's a
question which I should do uh is the
expectation that the world's population
is going to equilibrate at some number
in the foreseeable future or that it
will Peak and start going down or do we
not really know
so the current U.N the latest un
projections are that the world
population will Peak around the 2080s
and then decline from there
um these predictions are obviously very
sensitive to what they expect fertility
rates and stuff would in the future sure
not just in terms of declining fertility
rates in lower income countries but also
just sensitive to what happens to
fertility rates in rich countries do
they go up a bit do they stay the same
do they go down so I think there is some
sensitivity there
but there is the expectation that
towards the end of the century world
population will Peak
okay and is that just because people are
getting richer and rich people have less
kids or is it education or is it or is
it even sensible to talk about causation
there
so
causation but there's very strong links
that as countries develop so first as
child mortality Falls so rates of child
mortality tend to fall that they tend to
fall before fertility rates fall which
is why you can get pretty fast
population growth because chair
mortality Falls before your fertility
rates fall
um but then eventually fertility rates
do fall and that tends to be accompanied
by economic growth
um having access to contraception
getting women into education and careers
so there's a range of Social Development
um context there that that tends to lead
to reductions and fertility rates
Okay so
it's not that the population of the
Earth is going to double or triple in
the years to come and we won't have
enough room to feed them as we might
have thought in the 70s or whatever
we have enough food in some sense is
that did I get that impression correctly
from your book if we just figure out how
many calories we produce if we spread
them a little bit more evenly we would
have enough food to feed the world right
now
yeah definitely so I think when you
you think about nearly one in ten people
in the world don't get enough food to
eat in terms of calories every day so I
think there when you think about that
you might think oh we're we're maybe
like really close to just like just just
getting by on producing enough food for
everyone and maybe some people overeat a
little bit and some people just don't
get enough I think that that's just Far
From Reality the reality is that
we produce more than 5 000 calories per
person per day that's how much we're
producing now what we get at the end of
the supply chain is much less than that
but this is not a
the way I like to think about it is this
is not a like a biophysical problem that
we just cannot get enough food out of
the ground if we were in that position
I'd be really really worried the point
is we can grow more than enough foods
that we need to feed a population of 10
billion is what we choose to do after
with it afterwards that's really the key
thing and that comes down to the human
agency like we have the decisions on how
we want to use that food and in
particular we've chosen to hand over a
lot of our land to cattle grazing and
I'll give you the opportunity to explain
to us how harmful that is to the planet
yeah so the
reasons
they start with Frozen calories pretty
with I don't know two and a half three
thousand per day is that we we feed a
lot of that food to
livestock and animals and the point
there is that they then convert them to
meet very very inefficiently
um so you basically you basically when
you feed feed crops to an animal you
lose most of the calories you're
basically just throwing it away now you
can argue that you're converting that
into good proteins and stuff but the
reality is you're you're wasting a lot
of food so when it comes down to cereals
for example only around half of the
world's cereals actually go directly
into humans
the rest of it either goes to animal
feed or goes to biofuels
um so that's one factor is the amount of
like crops that we're feeding to animals
very inefficiently but then beyond that
we've got cattle grazine which is using
um
large large pasture lands so if you
think about it half of the world's
habitable land is used for farming
around three quarters of that is used
for for livestock so either grazing land
or land for growing crops for livestock
and the issue there is that a lot of
that land has come from deforestation
and cutting down forests and
um going into to whale tabitats so it's
been by far cat organism has been the
largest driver of deforestation
so in terms of solutions to this it does
seem that it's a slightly different
issue than what we were talking about
before you know one of the happy things
about electric cars for example is that
electric cars turn out to be good there
it's an easy sell like you said they're
gonna take over because people want to
buy them are we going to have to rely on
personal choices and responsibility to
get people to eat less beef and lamb and
more plant-based Foods or is there a
more societal way to tackle the problem
I think I think I'm
a lot less optimistic on how rapidly
things can change there I think as you
say you can find a very good alternative
to a petrol car and an electric one I
think the the challenge with food is
that when there's a very strong health
component to it so it's very personal to
people and again I think food is just
there's just a very strong identity
element to what you eat and we don't
like people telling us what we should
eat in fact we often try and push back
and go in the opposite direction if
people try to do so
um so I think they are I'm less
optimistic about the scale of Change You
could argue that what you do with
electric vehicles and and petrol cars
you can basically do the same for me you
can almost recreate the same experience
the same texture the same nutrition
um
for the use of either plant-based
um substitutes which are actually
getting very very good or you could go
like high-tech with lab-grown meat or
cultured meat
um
they are there's I think there'll still
be a little bit more of a a barrier to
change because it's about putting stuff
in your body there's a strong identity
element so there I I could see that
transition happening and I think you
could almost recreate the experience I'm
just a little bit less optimistic that
you can do it quickly
well good I mean let's dig into this
just a little bit more because I I'm all
in favor of uh plant-based meat
substitutes and synthetic uh meats and
things like that if you if you have a
population let's imagine a hypothetical
situation where the population had no
identity connection to killing cows and
eating meat but really love the taste of
beef or lamb or whatever
is it just is it much better for the
environment if we can do that or does it
also just I I don't know how much energy
it costs to make a synthetic steak or
hamburger or whatever
yeah so the I think there's there's
various
um substitutes there so the plant-based
substitutes are just undeniably better
for the environment on any metric or
just much much better than meat I think
the the
lab-grown meat is not quite there
they're in terms of scalability and it's
definitely not there in terms of cost
um
from the kind of life cycle analyzes
we've seen where it basically tries to
quantify the footprint across like the
whole cycle so the energy and the
ingredient stuff that go into it
um from from the results that we have so
far the their missions and energy are
much much lower than
um then uh meat proteins but there is
like some uncertainty there because we
haven't done the scalability
um that would be required but my
expectation would be that the emissions
of these Technologies would just be much
much lower unlike electric vehicles they
would continue to get lower as we
decarbonize our energy I think the key
things with fossil fuels or meat for
example is
to some extent we've kind of we've
improved efficiency and stuff of these
Technologies over time but we're kind of
hitting the limits like there's only so
far you can go with these Technologies
yeah with Renewables or electric cars or
these these new technologies again
there's the learning curve where like to
some extent only at the beginning of the
journey and these can continue to get
much better over time
so the optimistic take here would be
that just as with solar power we went
from a situation just a couple decades
ago where it was prohibitively expensive
to now it's quite viable maybe the same
thing will happen with meat substitutes
in various forms yeah I think I think
one of the problems at the moment is
they're not that cost effective compared
to the Alternatives yeah so if you have
if you have a real burger and a
plant-based Burger next each other and
they're the same price or even if the
plant-based Burger is more expensive
your general consumer is just not going
to buy it and that's especially the case
if again thinking about the trajectory
of of lower income countries basically
there we want to produce really low cost
protein such again that they skip the
really high meat pathway that rich
countries have gone through but
hopefully they are if you could even
undercut the cost of meat in those
countries it wouldn't just be that okay
they avoid the meat you could actually
just improve nutrition at a much much
lower cost
and good so maybe the the take-home
wrap-up message here is the subtitle of
your book where you propose that we can
try to be the first generation to live
sustainably on the planet so you know
you've been a good sport for a whole
hour the podcast let's you know give
your utopian take now you know what what
is uh the lovely utopian future that we
can achieve
so again it comes back to the
the two halves of what I think about is
the like skills of sustainability
um we need to tackle what I think of as
the first half of the equation so the
human suffering or the flip side of that
since we're talking about Utopia human
flourishing Dimension to that which is
many of the metrics are unacceptable as
they are at the moment so I've
widespread poverty
um
5 million children die from preventable
qualities every year
um there are just still massive massive
Global inequalities and the aim needs to
be that everyone in the world can live a
comfortable life where they have good
health
um they have a good income they have
access to electricity they have access
to
um clean cooking fuels all of these
basic metrics that we might take for
granted now need to be scaled up across
the world
at the same time we need to reduce
all of the environmental problems that
we've discussed but I think as I
mentioned I think these can go hand in
hand if you can make
um abundant energy really clean abundant
energy really cheap then you can again
solve the first half of the equation
people can get access to electricity
um at a much cheaper cost the same with
um nutrition and food you can
potentially massively increase
nutritional standards are much lower
cost so it's these bringing these
together as these two realities where
everyone lives a comfortable life but
they do so with a very low environmental
impact
and how for the individuals listening to
the podcast can we balance our
individual choices to try to make the
world a better place I mean you point
out for example in the book don't worry
about the plastic straws everybody the
plastic straws are not really a driver
of anything major in the world but it
makes maybe I I never actually worried
about plastic straws but maybe it makes
you feel better if you use paper straws
and feeling better is good but do those
local individual choices matter much or
does it really depend on us pushing
political willpower forward
as I'm I mean as you imagine that's a
mix of both I think the
the key point when it comes to stuff
like the plastic straws and the plastic
bags
it's not necessarily that I'm saying
don't do the small things
I think my key point there is that we're
we get thrown at us every day you need
to do these 100 things to save the
planet and from what most people it's
completely overwhelming and we probably
only have some brain space brain space
to do a couple of things so my key point
is if you're only going to do a couple
of things do the stuff that actually
matters don't waste your efforts on the
plastic straws
um so it's about being smart with your
attention and your money and your your
energy so that you actually do stuff
that matters rather than wasting it on
marginal stuff what is your list of a
few things that do matter that we should
focus on
um
eat less meat yeah it's the first thing
um if you drive switch electric vehicle
um
heating on your home switch to a heat
pump or something move away from gas
okay if you can
um reduce food waste
if you can
um put a solar panel on your roof or to
somehow increase renewable energy within
your household for many people that's
just not feasible
um but those are really the the really
big buckets of your carbon footprint
and actually across the different
environmental problems that if you do
that stuff you're already making a
massive impact and the other big one the
other big one is fly less
from an individual there there's I'm
less optimistic that we find
technological solutions to that very
soon on the same on the flip side of
that I also
don't see very rapid moves away from
that from a social political perspective
I just don't see if anything I see
global flying increasing not decreasing
in the coming decades but also
presumably vote for leaders who Express
awareness and care about these issues
so the so you the the things I mentioned
are basically your like direct footprint
impact yeah I think when it comes to
your indirect impacts there are a few
the one of the big ones is political
um so one is vote vote for the leader
that actually takes these issues
seriously but also there's another
element to that where
leaders campaign based on what they
think their voters care about so it's
not just about what you put on the
ballot it's about trying to raise your
voice to make sure that politicians know
that we actually care about these issues
so they put them near the top of the
list
so there's the political lens there's
also as we've talked about the economic
lens where when you're buying an
electric car when you're buying the meat
substitutes when you're buying the solar
panels you are shifting the economic
curve of these Technologies for for
other people and the rest of the world
so basically by investing they might
still be quite expensive at the moment
but by investing in them early you're
basically shoving that cost curve down
for the rest of the world
well and you know read and write books
that encourage people to act in these
good ways so uh we appreciate you
contributing to that part of it Hannah
Richie thanks so much for being on the
mindscape podcast thank you very much
[Music]
foreign